this is a very interesting kind of final
point on the sarah pale and defamation
lawsuit if you haven't been following
the story
good for you i mean quite frankly good
for you former vice presidential
candidate sarah palin who was john
mccain's vice presidential running mate
in 2008 sort of like a precur she was
trump before trump
just cartoony ignorance
and um she sued the new york times she
filed a defamation lawsuit against the
new york times in which she said the new
york times defamed her
by linking her politics and her rhetoric
with real world shootings and sarah
palin sued arguing that it was
defamation now the trial was delayed you
might remember because sarah palin
coveted um then she was spotted eating
out at restaurants in new york city
while coveted positive i mean just a
gross vile woman but the big news is
that a judge has thrown
the lawsuit out
and somehow fox news is still calling it
a victory and i'm going to show you that
in a little bit cnn reporting
judge jed reikoff the judge overseeing
sarah palin's defamation suit said
monday he will dismiss the suit ruling
palin's team did not prove a key element
of the case
rakoff's ruling came while the jury was
already deliberating
rakoff said he will allow the jury to
continue deliberating and to reach a
verdict and then we'll dismiss the case
rakoff presented his findings a very
clear win for the new york times with an
eye towards an inevitable appeals
process the judge said palin did not
prove actual malice which is the
standard her legal team had to meet in a
defamation case this goes back to the
1964 case new york times v sullivan
which specifies if you're a public
figure and you sue for defamation you
have to prove that the offender knew the
claim was false or showed reckless
disregard for the truth the time said
all along it made an error involving
palin they issued a correction but palin
argued the publication smeared her on
purpose seemed like a big uphill battle
to prove that and rakoff has now sided
with the times and said palin's camp did
not present a legally sufficient
evidentiary basis calling it unfortunate
editorializing so
this is being dismissed this is a loss
for sarah palin fox news which operates
in opposite world is calling it a win
here's martha mccallum breaking news
interviewing um uh howard kurtz and
howard kurtz says well it sort of is a
win though i mean
take a listen to this pardon me
oh howie don't don't go away i've got
another question for you because we
actually are just covering something
that is breaking moments ago and i i
mentioned this to jeanine pirro and her
jaw dropped the judge has thrown out
sarah palin's case yeah judge jeanine
pirro was just shocked at the judge's
decision uh against the new york times
which was saying that they had defamed
her by suggesting that her pack had
something to do with the shooting and
killing of six people including the
injuring of gabby giffords what's your
reaction to this news well first of all
i think that sarah palin won this case
in the court of public opinion in that a
lot of uh
no she didn't what are you talking about
howie very damaging material to the new
york times came out about this editorial
accusing her of political incitement in
a mass shooting in arizona six years
earlier and has not made the new york
times look good but it has always been
the case that it would be very difficult
for the former governor to win this suit
because she's a public figure and
there's a supreme court standard about
having to prove malice or reckless
disregard what i don't completely
understand i love how in this case they
act as if the law as written is like a
technicality that's just inconvenient
for sarah palin even though like her
claims are completely true
the this is all the time they say this
is the law this is the standard we
respect the law and he's saying yeah
based on the law it's not defamation but
he's acting like it's some kind of
unfair technicality but really sarah
palin won and because this is just
breaking is why the judge would send the
case to the jury then say well she
hasn't proven the case as a matter of
law and apparently according to what
we've been told from the courthouse uh
allowing the jury to continue to
deliberate but the judge has made this
ruling uh that means barring an appeal
uh at least this phase of the case is
over for sarah palin but man i think
that she uh did a lot to shine a light
on the internal processes of the new
york times and it has been pretty ugly
she she really didn't actually and it is
just you know understand
the people that are getting their news
from this
they're hearing sarah palin was right
and she basically won but the judge did
something weird and so like i guess no
the new york times isn't to have to pay
but she basically won that's not what
happened the case was dismissed
the case is being dismissed you got some
of the folks from the new york times to
admit that they had made mistakes to
apologize for you know presenting things
that were not as they appear you know
differently than the
underlying facts even that's not really
true because the new york times had
already issued a correction like every
aspect of this is just not true but you
have to remember
who is the audience here the audience
believes now
sarah palin basically won the case i
mean okay legally she didn't and that's
the only case there is but she basically
won the case this is how fox news works
and you have to remember this is the
hard news hour
of fox news but what's being mentioned
here is just opinion and it happens to
be opinion that doesn't make any sense
if you're just listening to the podcast
today we'll have the clip from fox that
i played on our instagram which you can
find at david pakman show